what's going on cobra kai we're gonna
watch ourselves the pen ultimate episode
of season four called the fall we got of
course andrew gordon with us from the
movie source channel we got john so hit
that like button we mean a lot subscribe
and click that notification bell to get
accepted into the reject nation
also full-length watch as long as we
single with the time quarter over our
patreon page
and uh big thanks to all the boys over
at prepper all 12 of you for helping us
edit down this one video
we got our window wide open so you'll
probably hear a good amount of
background noise i just want to sweat
that's why i'm all bagged out today
but i wore beanie for some reason
let's do it
[Music]
last year this dojo came out of nowhere
and made it to the finals
they've got some new fighters
and they're ready to show the world
that they're the best of life
you're the best around no one's gonna
have a breakup though you're the best
[Applause]
there's a sex appeal actually back at
the tournament
first time since season one
defending champions and steal the most
badass name for a dojo
biased much
so we're just not gonna talk about
having a stingray
nope okay he's just dead now we're in a
hospital sensei johnny lawrence and
defending champion miguel
[Music]
nice
just like the the red jacket that he
wore in the first movie and he get let
mcgill wear two to the roller skating
dance i put that together too what are
you guys talking about
the red and black suit
welcome
to the 51st annual all valley karate
tournament
so it's going down in this episode that
guy should be doing ringside for wwe
events it's karate time it's not party
time maybe it's a two-parter i still
remember my first all valley where i
stood here proudly with my sensei and
elizabeth chu
let's get out there and show cobra kai
what we're made of
yes i said are you ready yes i said
sounds like eagle fangs moray a word
i'm still worried for miguel do not let
your emotions cloud your judgment
do not let anything
stand in the way of your victory that's
not a pep talk
that's an order oh god we're all gonna
follow sensei crease's orders today
aren't we
[Applause]
i love you chris we love you i wish we
could have heard their pep talk too mike
barnes
dimitri alexapolis from miyagi doe
karate will be showcasing the comments
he saw that in bloodsport
nice that
[Applause]
are you kidding guy
damn demetrius pretty good demetri is a
black belt
that was edited together really well
damn
oh i want a medal for bo once
damn he is kind of scary
like i can flip so much unless if you
lift weights you can flip
[Music]
earth
[Music]
he's gonna mess this one up
i spoke too soon miss lee
yeah
go kyler
[Music]
so safe to say cobra guy is killing her
run
[Applause]
six jesus hey forget that okay you all
did great besides the right on their
heels this is far from over how the hell
are we in sixth place
gold medals are ten points overnight
i'll give a [ __ ] about the math what do
we need to beat cobra kai
uh
i'm just going to say what we're all
thinking this needs to be his last
go-round as president the next meeting
i'm calling for a vote of no confidence
ron's joining us
episode 1
a vote of no reference
international superstar
carrie
carrie underwood damned all right sure
that was an easy get sure
yes i'll come attend a karate tournament
[Music]
[Applause]
this is going to take up the rest of the
run time of the episode hell yeah her
husband's a client
i fixed a crown fracture in his
maxillary insides we never doubted
geraron
80s montage
damn dimitri cheeto chop
whoa
[Music]
it's got like terry silver i paired him
up with the biggest guy in the world all
right guys scores two to two ready
[Music]
using the drum
it's like sons of [ __ ] they saw the
first two movies
[Music]
[Laughter]
like cobra guy
let's kick his ass
let's go over there right now
we have arrived
at the quarterfinals
we're going through this tournament so
fast
damn
blue beetle
that was not a pun reference on his back
[Music]
[Applause]
no come on
[Music]
she's been at this longer than you
there's no reason to feel bad i don't
feel bad i only trained for six weeks
i'm gonna be stomping all these weak ass
[ __ ] next year
the right female fighters get eliminated
and
miguel makes it to the final
and he wins then
technically
there's a chance good odds
good chance
don't screw this up i have another
miyagi dose secret that you can slip to
your friends
never
put passion
in front of principal
because even if you win
you lose
that's a really good philosophy i don't
think he's going to apply it right now
[Laughter]
damn dmitry dmitry is owning this
episode my dude your little friend's
lucky didn't have to face cobra [ __ ]
can't say the same for you though
oh you are going down
i'll make you kiss that man
he's always been a bully but that's not
who you are
that's why she broke up with him you're
not defined by your haircut you know i
mean
don't get me wrong i loved it i was
really digging the purple actually but
i liked you for your energy your
confidence oh
oh i
lost my confidence
kiss him
next up in the quarterfinals it's kyla
park of cobra kai versus eli moskowitz
ah baby's so happy
looks like you've got a fight to win go
get him tiger bringing her out to the
mat
everything good
never better yeah
who's that
the guy's going to win this whole
[ __ ] thing
[Music]
we're officially close to our rating
territory here gentlemen ready
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
he's a good kick damn man these people
learn fast
ravi said miyagido is for defense only
you got your defense
you have nothing
she's gonna learn what johnny taught her
just gonna jump off a building
my two dads
[Music]
oh
that was really good
it's almost as if combining your dojos
was a good idea
[Music]
noise sweep everything larusso yes he's
like i didn't teach her that i don't
know how johnny was like yes
how'd you pick up so much
why does it matter i won you didn't win
the right way
maybe my right way is different than
yours
don't i get a choice this is a
tournament after all the fact that you
made it this far at your age it's a huge
deal
brother's gonna be impressed
i'm ready to story out there
but don't think i'm going easy on you
now oh man
yeah okay wise ass
come on manipulate him again kenny don't
put passion before principal real snake
fight
it's cobra kai versus cobra kai this is
awesome we've never seen kobe kuipers
cover guy in a tournament
it's pretty good
timeout
just like in the first movie when he got
kicked in the face johnny timeout i
thought you wanted to be a champion
better back on your lines
oh my god you killed candy
we knew this was coming
fight
oh he's not getting another point
oh
jesus damn but i'm your friend robbie
at least the president's a dentist
lower back
[Music]
dude that's the future miles morales
come on is that legal it's the karate
kid world
real championship
none of this one didn't have gear
looks like it's me and eli and the semis
yeah should be a good fight it's gonna
do some miyagi though my friend
doesn't help that nobody's ever been
miguel either
[Laughter]
at least you know how to fight because
johnny taught you too
jesus sam
daniel's like that's the advice i was
gonna give take his ass out what take
his ass out hawk is my friend he's
fighting for larusso he picked his side
whose side are you on no johnny you said
are you one
what do you mean
you called me robbie man
i'm on your side
always
yeah
oh yeah i had that like hey i'm gonna
beat you not gonna hold back right
no
good neither am i
that's how the fight should go
holy [ __ ]
you're not a kid anymore you want
something you have to crawl across the
floor
i know you came
while he's flying you're going to be my
karate teacher
no
i'm going to be here sensei
whoa oh wow
that's exactly what i was worried about
that's exactly what i was worried about
oh
man
[ __ ]
i'll tell you i didn't see you coming
though right now okay
it's tommy mcguire spider-man 2 all over
again
[Music]
poor miguel
that's the first time we got different
music on the end credits all right
oh
how about that carrie underwood
performance yeah right
um
yeah i know when miguel was competing i
said i'm still worried about him but i i
didn't actually as show as episodes
progressing i like kind of forgot all
about her and i thought i guess it's not
a problem anymore for his back so it's
interesting that they brought it back a
rat and hahahaha
they brought it back around for um for
that in a moment that you don't expect
it that at all i was like [ __ ] he's
about to like murder hawker right now in
this moment isn't he
uh but i thought the episode overall was
great we're gonna hop into on our time
we're gonna hop into film in the finale
uh right away so um yeah i don't want to
spend too much time talking but i did i
thought the episode was really good i
thought the first half of this there was
something that was not quite
on point i think it was kind of moving
so quick they were like they were going
so fast through the tournament because
they were trying to get to like the good
stuff but the last half of this i
thought was like perfect i was like all
right good i've never really there were
things to appreciate in the first half
with some of the choreography a lot of
the editing especially watching dimitri
do a lot of form work
and whatnot like i was really enjoying
that but yeah it was right around the
time when you see daniel um noticing
that cobra kai is
you know adopting the miyagi doe moves
when the episode really started to click
and then everything after that was just
like freaking perfect the these
conflicts that are occurring like with
kenny and robbie and it seems like
robbie's taking that to heart don't put
passion before principal
uh there's there's so many great little
motifs there
but yeah i guess this is a two-part
tournament because i was my concern was
that i thought they were like i guess
they're just knocking this out of the
way right now and i thought they were
moving so fast in the first half of the
qualifications um but then as it went
you know i'm sure a lot of you guys love
the whole thing from beginning to end
but yeah overall i still give this a
pretty solid 9 out of 10.
um i got it episode 9 you gave it a 9
out of 10. that was
slick
andrew's always on it for these videos
always guys always always on it always
on it uh yeah and uh so uh who i guess
i'm tossing the baton here someone uh
talking about drugs are there easter
eggs and you're taking over easter eggs
what happened to stinker and how about
that carrie underwood performance and i
think robbie also missed a very key
moment line should have said here comes
the pain
but he didn't hear all right letter g
today yeah
it's the finale almost guys i'm sorry
just a little pump all right the easter
eggs i can just come up with one of the
kicks to the face i forgot which person
was on very similar the kick that dutch
gave to uh daniel in one of their fights
when we saw the two cobra kai fighting
each other which we've never seen before
in any karate kid iteration or in any of
the season one uh finale episode uh that
did remind me a little bit of when
johnny was explaining in season two when
we saw the original four gang of cobra
kai he said that i fought bobby in 1983
and uh
also i believe he said he fought uh
vidal in the championship or the semis
whatever but again that's just uh
reiterating to kobrikai fighting each
other we was mentioned in season two so
actually seeing it now uh also too we
saw
that woman who works for uh
the committee or whatever for the cry
she said that uh we're going to uh it
was a star wars reference where she said
i uh no order no confident vote to the
president very similar to how natalie
portman's queen amidala said no
confidence vote for chancellor valorum
in 1999's
amazing episode one phantom menace
uh let's see what else do we have your
breath control going right now
you're doing great buddy
um other than that oh and uh when they
call it when he calls a timeout uh after
uh robbie uh loses the first point to
kenny we see the timeout get called and
uh that happened in karate the first
karate kid where johnny uh went down 2-0
to daniel and then there was a timeout
called by the stunt coordinator the ref
pat johnson did a lot of other movies
you should go check up his imdb it's
really interesting teenage mutant ninja
turtles
and mortal kombat uh
but yeah that's another uh reference we
uh moment yes it is i love it well i
think that is a good a good reference
especially want to point out right now
because you know a lot of the robbie
keane path is trying to make sure he
doesn't go down the johnny lawrence path
and it's so often that when
sons who are trying not to be like their
fathers are there's so much uh
repression and angst towards their dads
they often end up becoming them because
of that
and so i could see how they're sort of
mirroring that with robbie but you in
other things here with hawk as well eli
as we should call him i think we should
just call him eli moon's boyfriend yes
eli moon and then also um you know this
whole thing with
the
teachers not realizing that their
students are probably better off with
adopting both styles instead of being
stubborn so john why don't you talk on
that a little bit yeah i thought that
was a really lovely through line of this
episode and i loved watching the
different web of entanglements happen i
mean it seems like for the most part
cobra kai is pretty unified but watching
yeah as danny and tangles over with
robbie and then johnny with sam and even
seeing him sort of overcome with like
yes my my teachings paid off somewhere
in this tournament with sam uh and two
just to get to relish in how good so
much of this cast is at the martial arts
like that like you said that montage of
them doing the different special skills
and even just the various fights as the
episode went on were nice and intense
and it seemed like they really made the
effort to show them going back and forth
to sell that authenticity which i
thought was really nice and uh yeah like
when we i agree that getting to the
tournament sort of felt a bit like whoa
quick at first but when we really
settled in and started to let certain
fights breathe uh i thought it was
really really intense and compelling and
it gives you those highs that you want
out of you know a tournament movie or
whatever and uh and yeah i like that
dramatic thing of you know danny and
johnny are still just as wedged as ever
in terms of their ability to see eye to
eye and yet you know their students are
directly right here proving the point
that even robbie is proving that you
kind of need as many skills at your
disposal as possible in order to meet
every situation for the different
circumstances that it presents uh so
yeah i love the way that the themes and
principles have been rolled into the
tournament overall and uh super excited
to see the the end of that yeah
uh i set him up for everybody didn't
talk about it andrew hawk
oh okay i love i loved what they did i
mean as we can all tell when you watch
this episode it just all takes a woman's
kiss to get your confidence
that's the key here but no i actually i
really do dig their interactions and
their chemistry and the whole point also
i guess you could somewhat call this a
reference where she said you know you're
not a bully and that's kind of why she
broke that's not college that is why she
broke up with him when he was bullying
dimitri she broke up with him in season
two and then he got that moon tattoo for
nothing had to turn it into uh grim
reaper acts but yeah no i did i did like
uh the way uh
that uh their intimate moment it was a
really good confidence boost for a hawk
um and i like a re i really do like this
season his uh character development i
really thought it's been one of the best
i mean all the characters have been
really you know given their due time and
all that but especially because there
was one episode where uh you know i was
like oh we're going this route with eli
but it's definitely uh not a cliched
route just his whole journey this entire
season so i really like what they've
done with his character and you know
just again like you know you don't need
it doesn't really matter that haircut or
whatever but you know just you know
about the way you feel and and you know
how someone else can possibly make you
feel i just i thought that was a really
nice intimate and really cool moment for
hawk yeah sorry eli well i think i i
think with the way the not that having a
mohawk is bad i'm just saying that i
think what i'm the mohawk
that appearance that look represented
for eli
uh was very much strongly associated
with the bullying mentality like he it's
that kind of thing it's like when
people go like guys go through a breakup
and they shave their head to feel like a
completely different person and that
had so much to do with his identity as a
human being and still and we even saw
like the way he would treat kenny at
school he still had a lot of those
bullying qualities so in some ways uh
the way cobra kai just uh you know took
over the tattoo parlor and straight up
shaved his head that might have done him
a favor in the long run because he was
able to go and pack to his ground itself
but can still obviously do martial arts
and yeah the confidence comes from
within and not externally so i think
that was really cool what they've done
with this character here so far yeah i
agree i think if he would have had the
milwaukee would have been able to get
that board down but which is me
he could have broken it with the points
of the most exactly instead of having
finally someone caught what i was going
for exactly do it like a saw he could
just kind of back and forth you know
greg loves a good bit
[Laughter]
become a superject today i didn't know
what to do thanks for joining us guys i
was like what's my line that i come in
with here
all right guys uh well thank you so much
for being here andrew thanks for
pointing out all the crap that uh
that i didn't notice
you're welcome notice what what i'm here
for pat johnson go look him up
apparently that's your big takeaway for
today's episode uh we we got to watch
the finale right now that's the main
thing to check out it's a what's the
longest one of the season let's get into
it people keep a lookout for that uh
leave a like and yeah we'll catch you
guys soon follow him on movie source
channel good work today andrew thank you
craig thank you
[Laughter]
someone's got a kiss from a woman
recently he's pumped
oh yeah
just on the way over probably touching
himself in the car ride over here
dude i thought i told you not to tell
anyone about that keep going but don't
finish
[Music]